hello I'm sahana Peters from Bangalore
i'm in class 11 and I'm have taken up
computer science my question is to mr.
Albert and it is that what do you see
the future for nanotechnology in four
people in comatose situations and
especially in developing countries where
money is a major criteria so I can say
you cannot separate a nanotechnology
from all the other technology and from
science in general what is important for
developing country is due to to study
for to have students being becoming good
in science in general and developing
then the technological level of their
country nanotechnology is maybe the most
difficult for developing country because
these needs facilities that very
expensive and difficult to buy in poor
countries so but the main thing is to
begin with science in general